الخلاف الامريكي الصيني بدا يضغط على
الشركات الامريكيه الموجوده في بكين
للمغادره بعضها ما يزال يمسك العصا من
المنتصف واخرى بدات بحزم امتعتها شركه
مايكروسوفت العملاقه قررت نقل مقرها من
بكين الى كندا حيث غادر نحو 40 باحثا من
افضل خبراء الذكاء الاصطناعي بالفعل الى
مدينه فان كوفر لانشاء مختبر جديد سيضم
خبراء عالميين
مايكروسوفت ليست الاولى ولن تكون الاخيره
فقد سبقتها سلسله من كبرى الشركات
الامريكيه كمجموعه العملاقه للصناديق التي
اغلقت مكتبها الرئيسيه في شنغهاي فيما
اعلنت منصه انها ستسرح 716 موظفا وستغلق
تطبيقها في الصين فيما حاولت شركه تصنيع
معدات الاتصالات اريكسون بعض عمليات
التصنيع من بكين الى الولايات المتحده
ودول اخرى
الانسحاب التكتيكي الامريكي من السوق
الصيني جاء بعد سلسله من عوامل رئيسيه
وفرتها لجذب الاستثمارات الامريكيه اهمها
العماله الرخيصه التي تقابلها ارباح كبيره
بالاضافه لتوافر الائتمان وسهوله وحجم
المدفوعات الضريبيه الاقل مقارنه ببقيه
الدول وتوفير الحمايه للاقليه المستثمره
خلاف سياسي بطعم الاقتصادي اداره بايدن
حركت ملف الخلافه مع الصين بشكل كبير
مؤخرا حيث بدات ببناء تحالف ضدها في
المحيط الهادئ والهدف تحويل مسار المنافسه
الاقتصاديه لصالح امريكا ومنع بيكين من
قياده العالم اقتصاديا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات